chargé des parrainages à la france
insoumise pour la côte-d'or patricia
marque récolte les retours de ses
équipes de terrain le démarchage et
ciblée à l'aide d'un tableau excel avec
les caractéristiques politiques de
chaque commune malgré ce travail
méthodique elle n'a pour l'instant
obtenu que 8 parrainage pour jean luc
mélenchon c'est très difficile pour
plusieurs raisons parce que bon beaucoup
pour des raisons politiques vous avez
toute la vieille gauche la gauche
obsolète qui appelait à 12 éliminé au
delà du calcul politique
les élus non encartés semble de plus en
plus réticents à parrainer
nous pensons que d'abord le système de
parrainage et anachronique et on
préférerait un vote citoyen par exemple
déterminer un certain nombre 150 mille
deux cents mieux faudrait que ces
citoyens cent cinquante mille deux cent
mille citoyens soutiennent soutiennent
la candidature d'un
représentant en septembre dernier lot
beaumier a débuté le démarchage pour les
parrainages d'eric zemmour quatre mois
plus tard il se dit satisfait le bilan
est plutôt positif d'abord on a reçu un
très bon accueil tant chez les
concitoyens que chez les mères
clairement la côte d'or et la bourgogne
franche comté sont des gros pour
ailleurs de promesses de parrainages mes
valeurs actuelles les promesses peine à
se concrétiser à reconquête on estime
que le seuil des 500 parrainages il est
sans doute nécessaire en tous les cas il
est crédible ça permet aussi de faire la
différence entre un candidat qui est mal
préparée ou un candidat combi
fantaisistes en revanche en effet on
entend et on rejoint aussi de cette
position qui est assez largement
partagée chez les mères de l'anonymat
des signatures pour envoyer un message
clair en tous les cas que parrainer ce
n'est pas votée il reste tout juste un
mois aux candidats et leurs militants
pour obtenir les 500 parrainages